today's topic brought to you by uh our
boys overseas in
the uk the united states essentially uh
this guy who's from the uk said
men should go east to go to eastern
europe to meet women because the women
over there are more attractive
misty is your blood boiling yes i'm
almost so angry i can't talk
actually um are you just moaning all the
time well
well that's one of those things about um
one of those criticisms right it's like
saying somebody can't take criticism um
it's very difficult to come back from
that yeah but i've got an answer for it
i haven't got an answer um about being
entitled and overweight
well no i think being entitled is
blaming your lack of relationship
success on an entire
nation of women very successful in
england very very successful but i
noticed that
every time i saw a beautiful woman and
when went to talk to her where are you
from oh sweden
oh russia there's no beautiful women in
the union no there are for sure
a lot of them are foreign in london and
it's just comparatively there are way
more in russia so you know you walk down
oxford street you see
a few beautiful women many of them are
foreign you walk down the equivalent
street in moscow it's like my god
you know is the they're everywhere a
woman from the uk is going to be pissed
off listen to this
someone that traveled is going to
understand what he's saying
that's all i'm saying we're not all
created equal and there's definitely
more beautiful people in certain areas
than others and
well beauty subjective yeah but we we
stop societal beauty norms you know we
do it is what it is
and and and look at the top models what
are their last names always
ska ova all of that the
the the the end you know i mean it's
like
come on now and it's the same thing for
men same thing for men
yeah but i think i've home girls will be
like man when i go to specific spots in
the caribbean or when i go here the men
are so much more yeah
i've said this i've said this about this
about here
like just here the racial of beautiful
man to a beautiful woman
is one beautiful man to 31 beautiful
woman yeah
the ratio is off am i pissed off that i
just called myself
not that attractive it's just a fact
it's wonderful
it's amazing it's just a factor you know
how wonderful it is to have so many
attractive women not enough attractive
dudes
it makes average dudes like me slide up
in like hey man i could try
i'm not saying i can dunk like he can
but you know what i mean i can lay it up
baby
i can't dunk like he can but i got balls
hey let's go
i'm just saying it is what it is do you
think there were any other reasons why
you weren't particularly successful with
british women when you were i was very
successful
like i said you're not listening to what
he's saying yeah they're the crowd
yeah and you try to so why are you uh
not successful i was very successful
with other women it's just that whenever
i noticed this it was a lot of so why
are you
not successful with so what you're
saying so what you're saying like that
yeah
like that kathy newman with jordan
peterson yeah so what you're saying is
that you weren't successful because
you're an ad
when i went to russia i found the whole
package the looks the character
everything
your mother's english right yes she is
so does she also qualify as
unattractive stupid entitled than the
rest of it or is she an exception
no but she lives out there with me and
she agrees your mother agrees all
english women are awful even though she
agrees that they're better out there
right she says they're lovely honest
people
kind and there's beautiful women
everywhere i think you're just peddling
like a really
dangerous like stereotypical view of
beauty
you have to understand the reason why
now right now what i hear is people that
are being butt hurt
but let's say for example i went to
russia not anywhere
in russia i went i went to saint
petersburg and the reason for that is
that in russia there's more
beautiful women than men there's more
women than men
because of alcoholism suicide
war there's much more women than men
that's that's like a fact fact so you
have to take that into accountability
it's not just like
it's not just the water in the country
or just some magical thing that happens
in ukraine
that makes the woman beautiful there
there's a lot of
there's a lot of political facts and
things
and events that happen that make that
happen
you know what i mean lucy nicotine is a
company founded by a caltech scientist
as well as former smokers
looking for a cleaner better nicotine
alternative
lucy's bringing you guys nicotine gum in
a variety of flavors everything from
pomegranate cinnamon and wintergreen i
don't even know what wintergreen is but
i'm gonna try that soon because i'm in
canada and it's cold up here and what's
great about these flavors is that they
actually taste great so while you're
trying to kick
the habit you don't have to kick your
taste buds
feel me here's the thing i've dated
people before who smoke
and no matter what they do you could
taste something like you ever tasted a
girl
taste it no not taste it you know i'm a
kiss to curl
if she smokes and you can taste the
you know but with this you can kick the
habit and if you're not going to do it
for your own health
and your own health reasons do it for
the people around you because i'm
telling you if you smoke and you smoke a
lot
we can tell i promise you we can tell
and it's nasty and thankfully here at
admin preach we're going to be
helping you guys to get 20 off all
products that you can buy
then they're going to be shipped
directly to your door so you have to
leave your home
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
so go to lucy dot co
to get your products using promo code
abba that's aba
all right um that is just so
damaging for women and men complain to
victor a secret you know if you like
those kind of women then
that's that's what you'll find in russia
if you don't like that kind of women
then of course i
i mean i meet guys that have all kinds
of different tastes right i meet guys
that have taste that don't
you know don't coincide with mine at all
and that's fine but for guys that
you know like that stereotypical
beautiful woman
that's where you will find profiling
people by where they come from
do you i have concern about that i have
a concern about the fact that you think
all british women
are overweight not all obviously i mean
actually
more british statistically if we're
talking about the obesity problem in the
uk which is a slightly different debate
but actually more british men are
overweight
he didn't say that the men are
attractive these people are so butthurt
they're trying to find a way to like
take apart what he says the truth is i
think there is an obesity problem in the
uk
comparatively to other european
countries it is what it is
i'm pretty sure it's the fattest country
in the uk
here it is the uk is the most obese
country in western europe the uk is now
the second fattest nation in europe and
brits are dying in three years younger
wrap it up we're good yeah like he's
stating facts here the thing is
this whenever something is not fun to
hear
there might be some truth to that there
might be some facts to that you have to
see
why he's saying that there is a reason
for that there's a social economic
there's social there's historical facts
there's
all of these things that you have to
take in accountability sometimes it's
not fun to hear
but it is what it is three english women
here uh brazil are they all
fat entitled stupid i mean i i don't
know
about what's your view of the world you
don't know them but you the book
cast your expert eye over the women at
this desk for example
i think that that that would be rude i'd
like to know let's hear you be brutally
honest
well i i don't i don't know
i've got respect for the women you've
got no respect for english women
that's the whole point i'm generalizing
you have zero respect for english women
you aren't
are you expected you've got respect for
me
when you're actually confronted when
you're actually confronted by
smart intelligent beautiful women you
can't deal with them can you of course i
can i'm dealing with it
say what you want to say i don't have
faces i want to tell you that the women
are more beautiful in russia
shock you know and they're very nice a
great honest
intelligence tell you that you're an
idiot for thinking those things is that
what you call nice
who's they what russian women
tell you yeah you do fluent russian ish
so they can't really understand a word
you're saying can they
did your wife even know what are you
doing
what is that yo you're so butthurt
that the lyraco yo
the the oh man the mental shortcuts
that to take you take to bring to your
point in
just to insult this man back you're not
even trying
to understand this point your butt hurt
and you're trying to reply to
your butt hurtness that's what you know
you're none of what you guys are doing
here
is constructive because you're not
trying to understand his point
you try to insult them back he said
something
that you took a certain way now you got
butt hurt
and now you're just responding with your
butt
not with your brain she speaks perfect
english and i speak very good russian
right see yeah yeah yeah
my name is my name is dick and i want to
marry you exactly yeah
who are the men that you're helping who
currently these
these hugely attractive men who are
highly intelligent
and want to have successful committed
relationships
how come these incredible men are not
finding women here in the uk
i'm a dating coach i've been doing it
for 11 years i've got successful
companies turned over 50 million dollars
we've got million website
visitors a month these guys are
listening to me they want my advice
and a lot of them are very unsatisfied
and the guys that have come and visited
me
in eastern europe in russia like wow you
know this is like a breath of fresh
air as i said many many men are going to
be really happy with english women
that's great can i just say
the men that i'm satisfied they can
listen to me they can take my advice and
they might end up very very happy
that's that's my job i think i think
like
you're suggesting that there's a cheats
way to being confident and right with
yourself
and that cheats way is to just move
abroad there's a cheat way
of being confident in yourself is that
what you said a cheat way of being
confident in yourself like what
having boob implants
makeup changing your hair color true
true
there's a cheat way for everything you
know what i mean that doesn't make it
wrong
it's just make it what it is hey man
listen if i want ladies with fat asses
you know what i mean there's a couple
african countries i'm going to go visit
there's and in order to be like
available in a relationship
you just have to do the hard work to
feel right with yourself and be able to
have to love yourself and if you do that
you're going to find people as the girls
wearing makeup anyway
i think you are right to seek your
future in russia because i think the
chances of you ever having sex
in this country again are zero um but
it's been it's been very
respectful but you're married why would
you say that
it was just funny to watch people get
butt hurts but but hurt and responding
did he lie it doesn't mean that all the
women you care about doesn't mean that
you're necessarily
ugly if you're watching this it just
means that on average it's gonna be more
likely listen everybody it's like me
saying
that if you go to certain places there's
gonna be more crime
are you saying that they're all criminal
no it's just more crime
all right when you go to certain
countries better watch out because it's
different over there
in that same token people look different
in some countries people are taller
in others they're shorter it's not my
fault that filipinos they love
basketball but they short
it is what it is man they love that they
love
basketball
there you go you take the porn you call
your cousin
and you set up a match hey man i don't
even know but what i'm going to say is
like yo
there's something ironic about like one
of the shortest countries in the world
loving basketball that's funny
but it is what it is up there if you
want to see tall basketball players
probably go to america probably go to
latvia from the side country you know
you go to latvia they play basketball
and they tall
so it is what it is but anyways i don't
know it was just funny watching them get
butt hurt
uh i had a good laugh but if you're from
the uk tell us what you guys think is he
lying
are most of the beautiful women in
london foreign
do you think that there are more
beautiful women in other countries
we want to hear your thoughts good good
[Music]
much